[Captions by Y Translator]
In today's video,
we're going to show you
how to take a couple
of paint sticks,
and a dab of wood glue,
and turn it into a functional
returning boomerang.
[Music]
Boomerangs are pretty cool,
originated in Australia.
It's a stick with a curve in it
with some shavings
and carvings along the sides
that make it so if you throw it correctly,
it will actually wrap around
and return to you.
This one's bought
as a souvenir in Australia,
and today, we're going to be
learning how to make our own.
They are going to look
quite like this.
They're going to be
a different style,
but they're going to be made
out of paint sticks.
This whole project
will only cost like 20 cents
per boomerang that
you want to make.
It's a really cool project,
surprisingly easy,
it goes together quickly,
and it's a lot of fun when
you finally get it to throw,
and actually wrap around
and come back to you.
Here's the basic idea:
By gluing to paint sticks
together in the middle,
and by sanding each
of the four arms
into a basic Wing shape,
we create a functional boomerang
that will return when we
throw it properly.
Now, paint sticks are available
at most places that sell paint,
most hardware stores.
These particular ones
are from Lowe's.
You can get them
from Home Depot or Ace,
or whatever you feel like.
Whatever your local
hardware store is,
they probably carry
something similar.
I grabbed these ones.
They actually just
let you take a couple
of them for free,
and so, we're going
to be gluing these together,
and then shaping
them to turn them
into a working Boomerang.
Before we do anything else
with them, we need to see
if our paint sticks have
any curvature to them.
Sometimes, they will, sometimes,
they'll be perfectly straight.
But if they do have some curve,
we want to know about it.
So let's look right down
the line of the paint stick.
This one is pretty straight.
But I think it is curving
just a little bit.
There's another test you can do,
which is to lay it on a flat surface,
and see if pressing
on one side makes
it rock back and forth.
This one doesn't seem
to have much curve to it.
I think it might have just
the very very slightest bit
curving this direction.
So we'll leave that facing up.
Let's see on this one.
This one definitely has a curve.
It's far more extreme
than the other one,
but still pretty mild overall.
That's right, setting it down.
You can see that this one
does move a little bit
as we poke on the corners.
If you flip it over, it's
not a perfectly level curve.
This stick is slightly twisted,
but I think it will still work.
So on both of these,
if there is any curve,
it's curving up
in this direction.
So right now,
they're both forming
a very very shallow bowl shape,
and we want to make sure
that we keep that as up.
That's the side that
we'll call the top.
It's the side that
it's curving up to.
So like a hand that's open.
Like if it's curling,
it's going to curl up
not down and backward.
In this case,
it's easy to remember.
There's lots
of paint on one side,
and so we're going to call
that those the bottom.
The plain sides are the top.
So now, what we want to do
is find the exact centers
of these paint sticks.
This particular kind of
paint stick is 12 inches long.
Both of them 12 inches long.
To line these both up,
we have the 6 inch mark on one stick,
and the 6 inch mark on the other stick.
So the 6 inch mark on this one
needs to line up with the center
on this stick.
Similarly, the 6 inch mark here
needs to line up with the center of this one.
By doing that,
we should end up
with our paint sticks perfectly
centered on each other.
Now, what we're going to do is
add a little bit of wood glue,
and then clamp them down,
but not all the way.
While it's slightly clamped,
we'll make sure everything is
nice and square with our square.
So let's get a little dab
of wood glue on here.
This is more glue
than I'm going to need.
It's going to squeeze out
the sides quite a bit,
we'll just clean it off.
Now we want to line up
the marks with the centers.
Now, we're going
to take a clamp.
You could also probably use
a clothes pin for this,
if you don't have any clamps, like I do.
It just needs to hold it together.
It doesn't even need
to hold it super tight.
Just well enough.
All right,
but now you can see
that while they are together,
they're not really square,
and that's why we haven't
tightened this down too much.
We now need to take our square,
and adjust these sticks.
So they're actually
at 90 degree angles.
Now, it's glued together,
being held together with the clamp.
Now, let's let the glue dry,
and then we'll come back
to the next step.
Our glue has had time to dry,
so we can take off the clamp,
and we can see
that the two pieces hold
themselves together quite well.
Now, we need to shape each
of these sticks into sort of a wing,
and we're going to do the
same thing on all four arms.
On a boomerang,
there's a leading edge
and a trailing edge, and it
has to do with what direction
the boomerang is spinning.
I'm right-handed.
This is intended to be
a right-handed Boomerang.
So for me, when I throw it,
it's going to be thrown
like that.
That means this will be
the leading edge,
and this will be
the trailing edge.
So this one, and this one,
and this one, and this one.
Those will all be
the leading edge
as it spins through the air.
I'm going to sand them
all about like this,
and we're going to try and
stand it from about this line
till it takes off about half
of our paint stick's thickness.
So we want to sand down
to about that line.
The easiest way to do that is
to just grab some sandpaper,
and a block of wood,
and start sanding it down.
Paint sticks are pretty soft
so it doesn't take too long.
So this is how we want
to sand down all
of our trailing edges.
The leading edge,
or the front of each of
our arms, we want to round off.
We're not trying
to take off as much wood
as we are in the trailing edges,
but we want it to just be
a nice rounded shape,
and we're going
to do the same thing
on these edges.
So, this corner, this corner,
and these corners, we just want
to be nice and rounded.
[Music]
Trailing edge has
this nice taper coming down
to about half the thickness
of the paint stick,
and the leading edge
is rounded right around,
as well as this top edge.
Here, I've just done a really
quick slightly enlarged view.
This is approximately
what the cross section
should look like.
This is the leading edge,
nice and rounded off.
This is the trailing edge,
where you can see
that it just tapers down
to a smaller thickness,
and this is our basic wing
shape that we need to sand
into all four arms.
We've got all four
of our arms sanded down
into our wing shape.
So at this point,
I think we can take this out,
and test if it's working.
All right, time to test
this boomerang out.
I've got my
appropriate headgear.
We're here
in a big empty field.
Got a proper accent.
Time to throw a boomerang.
I don't actually know
if that's a good Australian accent or not.
That's not the point.
Let's test this out.
See if it works.
Now, I have built
and tested these before,
and what I've found works best
with this style is throwing it
almost straight up and down.
With traditional boomerangs,
you'll usually throw it
at more of an angle.
With these ones,
what seems to work
best is throwing it
straight up and down,
and if you're looking forward,
then you throw it
a little bit off to the side,
and it should just wrap around.
Let's try this out.
[Music]
If I were any good at catching,
I would have caught that.
[Music]
Hit the cameraman.
Sorry, Mark.
[Music]
When there's even
a little bit of wind,
it can affect it quite a bit
because it's so lightweight.
[Music]
This is working pretty well.
Let's see what happens
if we throw a little bit of color on it.
[Music]
You can even hydrodip these
if you want a really exotic,
cool paint job on them.
[Music]
As you can see,
there's a little bit
of variety in how they fly.
You really just need to practice
with the boomerang that you
make, to learn how it flies,
and how you need to throw it.
And of course,
the wind is going to make
a lot of difference as I said.
GoPro strapped to a Boomerang,
will it work?
[Music]
It was totally real.
We didn't take that at all.
Sometimes, you can even
throw two at once, like this.
[Music]
That's how it's done.
Roll the 20 takes
that they didn't work.
It worked.
The paint sticks
are ten cents each,
if you even have
to pay for them at all.
As I said, some places
just give them away.
A little bit of glue
and some sandpaper,
and you're done.
Bringing the total cost
of one of these things up
to like 25 cents.
They take maybe an hour
if you include how long
you have to let the glue dry,
and they are tons of fun.
It's really cool to take one
of these out into a field,
and it takes some practice.
But when you finally
get it to return
so you can just catch it,
it is beautiful.
Hey, that one came back.
Nice.
One out of seven.
Guys, we've got more
for you to see.
That box at the top
will take you to our last video,
and you should check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you haven't subscribed yet,
hit this bomb to get in the club.
That way, you'll never
miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.